[Aplausos]
o mundo tá chato né gente
hoje a gente tem a geração mimi que o
que seria um mimimi o mimi é uma
onomatopéia que imita o som das crianças
chorando e é isso que eles fazem eles
oram reclamam de tudo mas será que isso
é realmente negativo quando eu tinha 10
para 11 anos eu tive que trocar de
escola eu estava na quinta série e nessa
escola a maioria dos meninos me chamavam
de tição e eles questionavam também a
minha presença na escola
os meses foram passando passando
passando isso foi minando minando até
acabar
para ela isso lá na minha casa fora da
escola eu tinha todo um suporte era
minha mãe minhas amigas algumas
professoras que de maneira totalmente
empática sentia o que eu sentia e me
fazia levantar todos os dias e ir para
aquela escola
eu estudei lá até o terceiro colegial e
é por isso que eu acho que para muitas
coisas
não existe mimi porque hoje em dia as
pessoas falam
elas não sofrem caladas como eu sofri eu
sofri anteriormente calada e as pessoas
pararam de me hostilizar porque elas
achavam que não atingiu os objetivos que
era me fazer sair da escola ou me fazer
sofrer
existem alguns assuntos então que
um são mini o primeiro deles é esse o
racismo
o racismo é grega sempre segregou
existem umas pessoas que têm poder
privilégios e as outras ficam à margem
disso eu por ser negra por exemplo eu
não poderia freqüentar a mesma escola
das outras crianças né
apesar disso eu frequentei mesmo sendo
negra ea escola sendo privada sobre a
margem disso quem fica à margem 64% da
população brasileira os negros e aí eu
te pergunto na sua empresa 64% das
pessoas são negras na sua universidade
os professores e alunos 64% deles são
negros na televisão na revista a capa de
revista lá na banca
a maioria delas estão estampadas pessoas
negras
em contrapartida 67% das pessoas que
estão presos no brasil hoje são negras e
a cada 23 minutos
um jovem negro é morto no brasil
então são estas as oportunidades não é
insuficiente não é mm
se eu fosse homem hoje
de certo poder então não está viva mas
também se eu fosse homem lá na quinta
série
eu poderia não ter sido utilizada porque
eles poderiam me utilizar por causa de
uma
fraqueza feminina né
então meus amigos eu acho que o
feminismo também não é mimi né
hoje ainda hoje as empresas remuneram
melhor os homens e as mulheres a cada
sete minutos uma mulher é agredida e
psicologicamente moralmente ou
fisicamente no brasil a cada 11 minutos
uma mulher é violentada no brasil
sem falar da mulher negra que é uma
carne um objeto sexual não é digna de
receber amor muitas vezes não o
feminismo
definitivamente não é menino e agora é a
hora de eu ser empática e falado em prol
de todos do ser humano porque somos
todos iguais a todos
eu por ser heterossexual não sou o pior
ou melhor mind ninguém por sua
orientação sexual ou identidade de
gênero
entretanto segundo o the new york times
o brasil é o país mais perigoso para um
homossexual vive sem falar na
discriminação sem falar na falta também
de oportunidade de trabalho que eles
enfrentam
definitivamente isso não é me então
menino
sejamos simpático simpáticos com todos
afinal somos todos semelhantes
vamos analisar bem cada assunto mais a
fundo e não julgar ele simplesmente como
mimi e em terceiro lugar
estas três são uma das minhas lutas e
ninguém mais vai me calar
muito obrigado